[Musik]
[Applaus]
herzlich willkommen zum sport rapport
dem sport podcast des österreichischen
bundesheers heute zu gast frau zugführer
lisa hauser österreichs erfolgreichste
biathletin liebe leser herzlich
willkommen
das war ja ein unglaublicher winter den
du gefeiert hast die saison schon super
angefangen und du hast dann von
wochenende zu wochenende von rennen zu
rennen sich gesteigert mit dem großen
highlight weltmeisterin werden wie
schaust du zurück auf diese wahnsinnig
ja es ist unglaublich was in die letzten
monate bei mir abgespielt oder ich war
der dezember ist schon nicht schlecht
haben schießt und doch ist die troubles
kollabieren hauptmerkmal des career
service immer bis zu wollen ist es immer
nur oder größerer erfolg hannah ist war
irgendwie immer der aufsteigenden ast
und das war richtig cool und und für
diese arbeit war immer sofort und
konsequent daran dass man diesen mann
erreichen darf und muss bei der
weltmeisterschaft mit der goldmedaille
gelungen und das war schon sehr
sensationelle hast du das gefühl dass
die goldmedaille auch möglich gewesen
ist weil du eben im verlauf der
weltmeisterschaft so erfolgreich war es
vielleicht auch druck abgefallen ist
man hat sozusagen sein soll schon
erfüllt und alles andere ist nur
draufgabe oder wächst an der druckwelle
erwartungshaltung wächst weil sich jetzt
plötzlich alle erwarten sie super drauf
das heißt das kann was werden wir so
kriegst du das mit teils sportlerinnen
wenn man da bei der weltmeisterschaft
ist oder sind das dinge die dich gar
nicht beschäftigt haben manchmal kriegt
ist während der weltmeisterschaft
natürlich schon mit dass von außen so
viele kommentare sorgen dass metalle
erwartet werden
für mich war es schon sehr großer druck
vor der weltmeisterschaft dorthin zu
kommen noch mal im weltcup sieg bei der
weltcup davor und erwartet worden dass
er mit eine hohe und jeder hat gesagt es
ist möglich gewesen konnte ist aber man
muss doch wirklich einfach am perfekten
dokument die dichte im biathlon bei den
damen bei den herren ist so verdammt
dicht und in der sache man braucht einen
perfekten tag das mal mit aller macht
man braucht wahrscheinlich dass diese
zahl glück wo es dann nicht jede
athletin hat weil wenn man die
athletinnen und schaut die woz
genauso für podium immer die leistung
eigentlich reden aber auch an den dort
genau zum pastor seine substanz sekunden
pro sekunden am schießstand sein ob der
stoff runter ist nicht einfach nur als
zaungast und mir ist das jetzt einfach
verkündet werden dass ich einfach mal
ganz oben steht darf und es ist dann
schon natürlich mit der ersten medaille
in der mixedstaffel einiges an druck
weggefallen weil jeder gesagt okay diese
demonstriert alle die was ihr erwartet
hat und jetzt kommt eigentlich locker in
den staaten aber trotzdem macht muss sie
tanja eindruck erlebt man sie ihr ziel
auf ich hoffe zwar nicht irgendwie ganz
zufrieden sicher war die visite mit
einer bundes stehe aber irgendwie war es
mir doch was man drauf aber man würde
leistung erzeugen und ja im verfolgungs
bewerb das funktioniert dann mit der
silbermedaille war für mich sensationell
und ob den zeitpunkt war dann wirklich
für mich wo es bei der
b-weltmeisterschaft und camcordern drauf
gehabt also dass wir den familien
ankommt und ja es ist dann als ein
schlusnus gekrönt worden
du hast jetzt auch angesprochen dass man
selber eben diesen druck hat und man
merkt man merkt man kriegt ja mit es
läuft es geht ich bin gut drauf ich kann
das aber gleichzeitig wächst da ja auch
die immer erwartungshaltung und das auch
angesprochen dass eben der perfekte tag
sein muss was hat denn diesen tag wo du
im massenstart die goldmedaille gemacht
hast so perfekt gemacht was hat alles
funktioniert was vielleicht an anderen
tagen nicht immer 100 prozent
funktioniert wird was soll ich habe mich
von anfang an recht gut gefühlt auf der
auf der lippe bin zwar in der ersten
runde winter 30 mädels en forme in die
runde gehen gibt es relativ viele
komplikationen die uhr steigt jahr
dauern in china war verstecken die
schmeißt vor dir bergauf das waren zur
sache und irgendwie habe ich das glück
oder pech verfolgt werden weil in jede
komplikation was glück gehabt bin
irgendwie einig hehmann haupt irgendwie
der ersten klappe ich bin als
fünfundzwanzigster zum standard thema wo
er mit startnummer 4 vorne weggelaufen
hab da einfach vier plätze verloren
dafür wertvolle sekunden und ich glaube
vor den zeitpunkt stand es dann für mich
einfach kosten jetzt müssten konsequent
arbeiten und dann
ich habe mich gut gefühlt aufdrücken
habe mir wirklich viel führungsarbeit
geleistet weil man zu dem zeitpunkt
besser drauf wie die online athletinnen
und bot dann einfach spaß macht auf der
leute begeistern wo man wirklich sagt es
ist die quälerei ist macht spaß das
kommende version
das ist ja fast unverständlich wenn man
daher etwas was jeder leisten vista
halbiert leben das du da sagst da die
quälerei macht dann in dem moment spaß
kannst auch sagen dass du dir vielleicht
auch in diesem berühmt-berüchtigten flow
zustand gekommen bist wo dann einfach
jeder zug langsam passt jeder jeder
schritt passt wo du merkst okay jetzt
jetzt funktioniert es ja es ist wahr so
viel faktoren nehmen ich habe mich so an
gott führt ich hab' ich habe gute gene
und der meine vier skript haben dass ein
neues so faktoren was ist ein wahrer
held ist richtig cool zum laufen gibt
natürlich zusätzlich motivation und mama
ist es vergönnt gewesen dass sie ihr
einfach auf die schlussrunde gonna be on
schon sehr großen respektablen vorsprung
kopf boni von mir aus eigentliche
booster wenn jetzt nicht irgendwie was
großartiges schief läuft
conny die runde genießen und das war
vorher auf den letzten teil der strecke
ist wichtig für mich dass sie wussten
jetzt laufen als erster ins ziel und
cool das ganze genießen
wahnsinn hier das schreckt davor weil
ich würde wahrscheinlich so jetzt nichts
falsch mache jetzt nichts falsch machen
dann passiert ist und dann mache ich
also ich hätte das wahrscheinlich so
nicht kommen als vorgegeben was so
leicht weil bei der buch hätte zuvor bei
der mixed staffel medaille der varia
schlussläuferin und da wirklich auf
meine schlussrunde so wusste ich hab
zwei meter sind nach kennt die sind
nicht so weit weg und ich habe mir das
so verdammt schwarzer hose das war der
erste meiner sensor großen
drucksituationen war und dass sie die
metalle horn bringen oder nicht und dann
wasser teambewerb an oder ist was
zusätzlich irgendwie bisher immer mehr
nervös ist einfach was es ist ein
enormer rennen was jetzt versager gut
machen kann sondern ist ist eine drei
andere athleten und athletinnen mit
dabei und es war wirklich ein
schlussrunde
wohl irgendwie will man gleich mal
wieder vergessen weil man einfach mal
werd dann so unsicher wie fasten immer
wieder standen war irgendwie ja auch vom
kopf her dass die mentale stärke doch
nicht da war dass sie das das wars ist
es meistens sitzung glück ausgang aber
es ist sehr sehr schwierig für mich also
ist die dynamik da auch wenn man weiß da
hängen andere dran das sind andere leute
die auch ihr bestes gegeben haben und
wenn es mir passieren sollte dass ich
jetzt also das ist auch ein faktor der
das ich dann im kopf mit abspielt also
voller also dass in der staffel in der
mixed-staffel war wirklich das erste mal
in der situation und der landi also der
lande dinge dominik da war es oft bei
den herren staffel schluss land verboten
hat ist öfter erleben wir sind werfen je
nach tiefe nötig weil wir dann die
medaille haben heute ist das natürlich
das schönste moment wenn es zum schluss
lay fans zu last und seine drei kollegen
stehen ihm zu und klein sie wolle mit
der drucker ist ist so situation nur mal
viel viel schlimmer wir einzelne die
schlagzeilen hat man wahrscheinlich
sowieso also wenn es klappt also laufen
aber nicht gehabt hat man genauso die
schlagzeilen die das dann auch
bekritteln auf jeden fall es ist dir in
deiner schlussrunde im einzel also die
masse statt dann auch gelungen
und du hast geschichte geschrieben du
bist die erste österreichische
biathleten überhaupt die eine
goldmedaille gewonnen hat bei einer
weltmeisterschaft was bedeutet dir das
ja es ist unglaublich gerne so viel zu
großes großer traum in erfüllung
gegangen großes ziel erreicht worden was
ist dann wirklich bedeutet so ein koloss
nie zu kurz ist die versorgung aber wenn
man jetzt so mit quellcode das ist ja
auf 1984 war mischa beteiligungen von
andrea groß in einer damen werden und
wer weltmeisterschaft und das ist jetzt
jedes jahr wo man weltmeisterschaft
wieder erwähnt worden und wieder die
geschichte wieder erzählt waren ja und
jetzt ist einmal gold gewonnen im
österreichischen sport bei den damen und
also ich glaube das werden sie jetzt 50
euro oder 50 jahre lang währt ist jetzt
an der zeit wäre
damals war die hause lisa die wahl
gehört und jetzt die geschichte wieder
aufgefallen und es ist dann schon
irgendwie cool ich bin auf jeden fall
auch überzeugt dass dann auch von seinen
weiteren goldmedaillen die folgen werden
unterrichtet wird und erzählt wird das
jetzt vorher angesprochen dass dominik
landertinger ehemaliger heeressportler
auch oft in dieser situation war ihr
trainiert ja auch alle gemeinsam im
stützpunkt in hochfilzen das ist ja das
biathlon mekka kann man sich da auch was
abschauen lernen von von diesen
schwierigen mentalen situationen von
diesen belastungen wie die anderen das
lösen gibt es dann ein austausch ein
miteinander genau ist in hochfeld 2 bei
uns eigentlich tagtäglich trainiert das
ist wirklich unser trainingsstätte um
unsere erfolge geschmiedet werden sogar
mal und man mittlerweile ist allein im
inland ist er für kontakt topmedia
trainiert und dort natürlich sehr für
austausch stammen
wie ihr seht ist machen mal die männer
sind doch immer große vorbilder wenn man
taktisch besser laufen können wenn man
technisch besser laufen können aber am
schießstand haben es mir a bisserl
fordern kinder von denen er weiß aber
recht große spaß und ja es wäre
natürlich schon sehr austausch haben
niederlande das mochte und ich habe halt
lande dannheimer medien telefonierte
noch so hell an die was du dafür oder im
abgeliefert horst bei den staffeln der
schlussläufer medaille zu ihm
jetzt war sie wohl fühlt und das ist ein
enormer druck
das heißt ein gegenseitiges lernen ist
da ich wage ich mal gerne was denn die
herren von euch damen in seinem team
alles lernen können sowas kann sich
einbringen wo die herren dann noch was
abschauen können von euch bei smava und
damit die herren ihn allerdings gruppe
und da war es wirklich so dass man
schüchtern sie wirklich fordern um
kinder weil man dort wirklich erfahren
niveau waren aber trotzdem mit einfacher
ist das schon bisher abwechseln wenn man
allerdings gruppe hat wo man vielleicht
gemischt dass gerber männer und frauen
zusammen trainieren weil die männer doch
hammer sein droht eine kämen wo immer
noch blödsinn quatscht wird
und bei uns dann vielleicht darauf zwei
richtung geht und so immer das passiert
durchmischten luke das ganze als bisher
auf die letzte letzten sommer dann in
der damen trainingsgruppe gewähren aber
jetzt im winter ist sein mir ja gott sei
dank immer mit dem heer an einem weg und
dadurch nichts das konzil wieder und
dies bringt der vida loca stimuli machen
wir einen blick an dem beginn dieser so
erfolgreichen saison und der beginnt mit
einer schwierigen situation für die
gesamte welt ich habe auch schon mit
vielen sportlerinnen sportler geredet
wie die pandemie phase erlebt haben
die maßnahmen die ungewissheit all diese
dinge die so plötzlich da waren euch im
wintersport hat es ja in dem sinne am
ende einer saison erwischt und ihr
konntet dann auf sie sind sozusagen in
die ganze ungewisse zeit gehen wie hast
du damals die beginn erlebt
er war zwar schon am ende der saison
2020 genau also immer so jetzt wirklich
sagen uns oder - wintersportlerin hat es
nicht ganz so hart treffen also wir
haben zwar letztes jahr also sehr
abruptes ende kommt der letzte backup
hat nicht stattgefunden und den weltcup
davor seine österreicher und hoc vom
letzten rennen handlungen also ich hab
in der ganzen saison letztes jahr einen
verpasst während in london im april
werden den strengen look down war es
dann für mich eigentlich recht angenehme
situation für mich ist story of schießen
dort steht erholung im vordergrund und
von dem her wo er einfach die ganze zeit
daheim und war für mich wirklich zeit
mal zum abschalten der zeit zum erholen
und auch mal gut du glaube also für mich
war das wirklich so schlimm würde mal
sagen dann ab mai haben wir wieder den
leistungssport ausüben darf wobei uns
die normale trainingsphase wieder
losgeht oder so ich habe so jetzt was
corona bedingt haben eigentlich nicht
viel verloren was ist training betrifft
natürlich baumaßnahmen muss man erfüllen
haben müssen aber prinzipiell seien sehr
dankbar und froh darüber dass mir gott
die ganzen oder einen den ganzen winter
lang am zu machen haben können wenn man
will dass der plan gewesen war das war
man sich auch als verschiebungen geben
wir haben die stationen corp wir waren
nicht in peking bei der vorpremiere für
juli
olympia und so aber prinzipiell alle
rennen machen china und das war nicht
selbstverständlich und es war natürlich
sehr froh darüber das ist bei uns so
funktioniert hat und sind sehr dankbar
dass der salzstock gefunden hat und ich
glaube das ganze land ist froh dass du
deine rahmen so stattfinden konnten
hätten wir deine leistungen nicht
erleben dürfen
du hast jetzt gesagt dass das du eben
die zeit auch gut nutzen konnte es jetzt
stelle ich einmal eine wilde theorien
den raum dann kannst du natürlich auch
sagen dass das ein vollkommener blödsinn
ist kann es vielleicht auch sein dass
das als als grundstein als basis als
fundament für diese so erfolgreiche
saison
diese monate wo halt alles ein bisschen
runter gefahren war pandemie bedingt
dass dies vielleicht auch gut getan hat
ja wer war's also immer so wirklich
sagen so wie es im april bei uns ist was
wirklich mal abschalten erholen wieder
die ganzen körperfunktionen irgendwie
wieder aufbauen weil man ruft da gehört
man immer die zeit zum erholen
man hat doch keine terminlichen
verpflichtungen korb und vielleicht war
es einfach ein vorteil was wo es mich
getroffen hat dass sie dann wieder
fitter in den staaten china mit dem
training
unabhängig davon glaube ich was bei uns
vielleicht da springen in der punkt war
durch das hygienische maßnahmen so
publik gemacht worden seien mit für ihn
enttäuschenden aufpassen mit mars
controller im winter jetzt dass jeder
immer geschaut hat dass er gesund bleibt
das war für uns eigentlich positiv mal
so sagen weil bei uns am
ausdauersportler ist dieses thema
gesundheit weil sehr wichtig war weil
sowohl die horse kratzern kapoor haben
eigentlich immer die hundertprozentige
leistung abklopfen kinder was man beim
weltcup rennen braucht und ich hab
einige staaten brauchen erstens würdiges
und eine kurs worten zu bewusst locker
gute leistungen bringen und für den
verband die ganzen maßnahmen wo es mir
herr kopper mit masken drohung hinters
infizieren mir sportlich haben wir immer
schon sehr sehr auf das geachtet für uns
war es jetzt wieder große unterschied
wenn ihm ein zimmer zurück im april war
sind wir schon immer das erste was ich
gemacht habe aber ein vorteil war dann
für uns sportler dann schon dass die
leute um uns herum einfach filme auf
passform und macht das jetzt durch die
auch gesehen dass bei uns im team für
viel weniger verklungen waren und damit
bessere ergebnisse zu dem das heißt doch
da wenn man sich traut damals auf das
schwierige und das vermeintlich
schlechte vielleicht trotzdem etwas
gutes heraus zu nehmen also dass es ein
learning finde ich wirklich sehr
spannender aspekt
ich glaube da können viele andere auch
aus anderen sportarten
ähnliches berichten die stadt jetzt dann
oft sie sind für die nächsten wochen aus
nach dieser so erfolgreichen saison und
vor allem mit dem blick nicht das jahr
olympischer spiele peking also wie wirst
du deine auch sie sind jetzt gestalten
ja also bei uns ist ja wirklich haben
eigentlich nur der april wo man mal
wirklich ostermonat freien training
stattfindet aber noch mein heiliges
essen haben sie relativ für türen auf du
mit interviews mit veranstaltungen auch
mit termine was man als sportlerin
einhalten muss wo den thw bis jetzt
relativ zum 30 aber ich glaube die
nächsten zwei wochen werde das ganze nur
bisschen ruhiger und wer wirklich war
sogar die zeit zu hause mag ihn ist wenn
man durch dann im winter für im weg ist
meine wird dann wieder einmal weil das
ist immer ein bisschen schwierig wenn
haie weile auch müttern und meine
familie einfach also wenig gesehen habe
bewusst da nie gesehen habe eben durch
das blöder die immer corona dass man
einfach bewusst gestaltet dass man sie
gar nicht trifft wenn die form geben
weil es einfach zu gefährlich war das
doch irgendwie in quarantäne mir so oder
so und die zeit werde jetzt dann einfach
nutzen dass ich wieder meine omas geben
die besucher und vielleicht aber freunde
weil weil die einfach ganzen winter
frost nixon habe aber das klingt auf
jeden fall als wir dass du wieder so
einen guten grundstein legen für eine
erfolgreiche session nächstes jahr
ich finde es spannend diese diese
permanente vorsicht und und so viele
dinge die man jetzt mit bedenken muss
damit man ja nicht irgendwo als k1
kontakt in quarantäne muss wenn man über
magen auch wettkampf muss auch immer
selbst nichts hätte also
das sind ganz viele neue aspekte die man
als spitzensportlerinnen und
spitzensportler neue mitdenken muss
jetzt du warst schon zweimal bei olympia
dabei noch und dekoriert wie wie gehst
du in das nächste jahr
peking olympisches spiele ich meine
erwartungshaltung der druck von externen
ist wahrscheinlich enorm
wie schaut es bei dir drinnen aus peking
denkt ja weil ich so in sotschi dabei
entscheiden dabei so jetzt fühle ich
mich gut dass das endlich da ist
aber ich freue mich drauf weil in
sotschi damals als juni athletin dabei
und hat doppelstock oder ergebnisse
erreichen kinder für diese undankbare
einer stufenheck werner überhaupt orco
die leistung abrufen china obama
schierstein bis jetzt kämpfen kopf und
es war für wind und ja und vor dem jahr
wieder nur sollte man zumindest kleine
rechnung abi seehofers olympia betrifft
es ist natürlich sehr spannend weil sie
nur alle vier jahre ist und immer sehr
besonderes erlebnis was die letzten 25
jahren betrifft was immer sehr
eigentlich hobby oder geschichten zu
unterziehen
und ja prinzipiell an der vorbereitung
werde jetzt nicht für anders mache also
august oder habe gesehen dass es
funktioniert und dass die leistung her
passt und wer jetzt da vor olympia
deswegen etwas großartiges umstände
sowie nicht auf den level bleibt wie
heuer war es das läuferische beschriften
und kutscher sehr sehr happy selber mal
kurz markus initiierten jetzt juroren
schritt machen hat dass man macht wie
bisher der fall war und bei den drei mal
drauf aber konsequenter zu arbeiten was
ist training betrifft im sommer abends
manchmal werden wird das nichts mehr
jetzt bewusst und ich freu mich drauf
und mal schauen was dann außer kind also
noch keine zielvorgabe ich meine es noch
lange bisschen aber wir wissen auf jeden
fall was du erreichen möchtest um die
rechnung zu begleichen
noch offen ist du hast jetzt auch gesagt
eben vertrauen ein bisschen den
eingeschlagenen weg jetzt nicht noch
einmal abwenden sondern weitermachen
zweimal bei olympia dabei sein
dass die engine angesprochen wo es nicht
so gut geklappt hat und auch sportlich
hast du schon einiges erlebt wo es nicht
immer so gut gelaufen ist
wie gehst du dann in diesen momenten wo
negative dinge passieren wo es nicht
läuft man vielleicht keine antworten hat
keine erklärungen warum es gerade nicht
funktioniert wie bleibst trotzdem dran
wie bleibst du trotzdem mental stark ich
hab natürlich für schlechte der rennen
dabei körper man muss mittlerweile
verkraftet mal schlechte resultat
irgendwie unterstand bis wir wieder
jugendliche kommen erinnern wo jung war
und aber schlecht zu einer dabei kommt
fasst jetzt erklärte woche das ist jetzt
immer öfter feuer und aber es gibt schon
ländern wo er wohl schon sehr uns wie
mit mir mit meiner leistung und bin da
oft aber schon zeit lang braucht zum
noch grübeln was mir zeit lang auf stadt
ärgert aber trotzdem am biathlon muss
mal seiner sportart wo es wirklich auf
den achsen doc und schauen konnte durch
durch dieses komponente doch sehr
abhängig ob mal kurz ergebnis macht oder
nicht
organische ganz ohne staus schauen und
so den castor schulhof da probieren
optimistisch zu bleiben
das ist aber nicht immer einfach ich
kenne das auch aus meinem eigenen leben
als sportler aber auch als mensch
dass man in diesen momenten dann wenn
man da sein muss wenn man trotzdem nach
vorne schauen muss wenn man sich ihn
nicht aufhalten lassen darf auch
wirklich viel abrufen muss von von den
lernens aus dem leben gar nicht nur als
sportler
ich weiß auch dass das du in deinem
eigenen leben auch schon schwierige
momente hat ist aus dem persönlichen
umfeld wo sich ja nicht einfach war da
trotzdem den fokus auf den sport zu
behalten
kannst du jetzt rückblickend sagen dass
genau solche dinge einen dann auch
stärker machen oder vielleicht die
perspektive ändern unter seinem hilft um
im sportlerleben und als mensch dann
trotzdem optimistisch zu bleiben ich
glaub schon nur so wenn man sich das
abseits des sports erleben wie es mir
sportler wie sand immer in uns eignen
würde und man ahnt medaille und erfolg
dieses usa
und es ist auch eigentlich in der
wirklichkeit nicht so also man muss das
macht mir schon bewusst sorgen dass das
uns sportler und auch gut geht mir der
von seiner leidenschaft ausleben
mit unseren sport nachgehen dem was man
so gern band und das ist
selbstverständlich und durch die ist das
doch in zwei 17er schwere zeit war für
meine ganze familie dass das abseits in
der familie einfach unfälle woanders was
zum glück mittlerweile wohl wieder gut
sein und euch wieder gesund sind haben
wir trotzdem ein bisschen
perspektivenwechsel glück dass er ja
medaille des erfolges ist für mich war
dieser schon sehr schwere zeit am
training geht auch an ihm interessiert
weiß thomas einverstanden ist es bauer
volle unterstützung vom eine drainage
wofür sei dank papilio war thomas
wassersport darauf auch nebensächlich
und nimmer das wichtigste und seitdem
klar wir kommen ja oder ja vielleicht
mit mit schlechte ergebnisse vielleicht
revision gehen das ist auch da auf lange
sicht
gott sei dank alles wieder gut auf lange
sicht auch viel mitnehmen können aus den
schwierigen momenten die vielleicht auch
ein grundstein sind dass es jetzt auch
so gut funktioniert und das training das
ist auch angesprochen dass das auch
erfolgreich wieder aufgenommen hast und
sich aus zeit anscheinend und vor allem
das training stelle ich mir wahnsinnig
kompliziert und hart vor weil er alle
disziplinen ja auch so verschieden sind
verschiedene distanzen verschiedene
aspekte die dann in den einzelnen
disziplinen eine rolle spielen kannst du
das sagen was du da am liebsten hast
oder geht das gar nicht als biathletin
natürlich hat jeder seine
lieblingsdisziplin ist es an der balance
bewerber dabei wo man filmisch ist oder
wo man es falsch ist
staffel bewerben dabei
was für die zuschauer sehr spannend ist
was für uns auch cool ist zum laufen
weil es für das team ganz gut ist ich
persönlich habe sie nicht wirklich vor
lieber so gemein
natürlich sind die bewerbe mit vier
schüssen massenstart oder verfolgungs
bewerb wie persönlich ganz gern dass
einzelne schon wieder besitzer
eigentlich weil es einfach 15 kilometer
sein und die sich der recht langes und
anspruchsvoller parcours ihr trennen
werden gemeinsam gestaltet also richtige
vorliebe was in jeder wenn wir jetzt
druck da gibt es dann erst im nachhinein
eigentlich wissen dass sie in allen
einzeldisziplinen oder das meiste wasser
statt einzelverfolgung sprint betrifft
überraschung podiumsplatzierung
kommission dass sie in irgendeinem
bewerbe gewisse vorliebe hätte und wir
hoffen natürlich dass er weiterhin
inhalt ist die pläne so facettenreich
und erfolgreich bleibst lisa herzlichen
dank für das spannende gespräch für die
einblicke in sein leben auch als
sportlerin aber auch als mensch und
natürlich viel erfolg viel gesundheit
und jetzt mal alles gute für die
erholung das war es von uns vom sport
rapport ich hoffe ihr habt es einiges
mitnehmen können und lisa hauser näher
kennen lernen können wir freuen uns wenn
ihr wieder beim nächsten sport report
mit dabei sein bis dann
[Applaus]